wild card game on TBS he's calling that
game in Arizona
first pitch eight eastern time between
the Rockies and Diamondbacks and he
joins us now here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Ron
I'm doing great rich thanks for having
me what do you think of last night's
game oh geez
I've never quite seen a first inning
like that in a postseason game to have
not only the twins jump out to that big
lead but for Santana to give it up
straight away a veteran pitcher that was
a quite surprising so what do you think
was the difference last night well I I
you know obviously Robertson's work you
know yeoman job of going three and a
third was huge but I I just think you
know when you when you see the Yankees
and their lineup you know we tend to
just think of judge and and and the rest
of them but you know Gregorius has had a
great year the depth of their lineup is
underrated I believe and you saw it last
night so what does it go through young
kids mind what was your first postseason
start like you were supposed to start
was against the Astros and it was five
innings of just utter mediocrity
in the Astrodome it was at the big Shea
and and I think what happens is that
we're going to see this maybe tonight
with John Gray is that you know instead
of brace embracing all of this extra
adrenaline that you have going sometimes
you try to deny it and you know uh I was
I found it interesting watching suberino
pitch last night we always think of the
radar gun is that it says a big number
that means the guy must be really good
but for Severino hovers around 95 when I
saw 97 98 on his fastball I was thinking
boy he's extremely pumped up and it's
gonna be hard to kind of figure out how
to throw his breaking ball to so the
radar gun can work in different ways you
know most of the time to tell she the
guys throwing hard sometimes it tells
you that maybe he's too amped up well
the gray that many people are familiar
with coast-to-coast might be sunny more
than John tell me about this kid that's
pitching for the Drakh Easter night and
for those who might not know about him
his stuff and his ability to maybe get
the Diamondbacks out and send them home
you know that's a great
point I think rich is that most people
don't know John Gray you know he's a
number one pick always destined to be a
number one kind of starter hasn't really
hit that stride until the last part of
last year and then he was hurt the
beginning of this year and then was
outstanding down the stretch are you
gonna see a guy who throws 95 plus good
breaking ball if I could equate him to
anyone that maybe people have seen a lot
kind of a Gerrit Cole for the Pirates
that kind of stuff and it's gonna be fun
to watch you know I mean everyone always
talks about no postseason experience
well you know you don't get it until you
there so he's a guy that has pitched
well against the Diamondbacks for known
his last five starts against them and
he's also pitched well at Chase Field
which is a real hitters ballpark so you
know look for him to do a lot better
than the starters last night in the
Walker so I had Aaron Boone on
yesterday's show and he said if you
could put the Indians on sodium
pentathol they'd be rooting for the
twins last night would have been very
happy I guess after what was half inning
a play put the Dodgers on sodium
pentathol who are they rooting for
tonight do you think they're rooting for
the Rockies you know they have not
played well either against the Rockies
or the Diamondbacks substitue see or
series they lost considering their 103
games but it's the Diamondbacks I think
it's not only tonight was that cranky
but Ravi Reyes another pitcher that no
one knows about that had an unbelievable
year Patrick Korbin has come back to the
what he did in his freshman season after
going through Tommy John surgery I think
their deeper in their starting pitching
I think their lineup has great depth the
only issue I think for the Diamondbacks
or maybe two things one their outfield
defense it's not great it's good but not
great and I think the bridge to get the
ball Archie Bradley who had an amazing
year is is not as deep as other teams or
like the Yankees well I mean and then
I've got Ron darling who's calling with
Ernie Johnson tonight as well he's gonna
be calling Cubs Nats beginning on Friday
on TBS and he's calling tonight's
wild-card game
Colorado and Arizona on TBS 8:00 Eastern
Time
Verlander starting for Houston that's a
big pickup obviously that happened in
all
we're gonna see Jose Quintana for the
Cubs last night we saw Robertson and
Cain leave for the Yankees in terms of
an a trade deadline situation
not many people talking about JD
Martinez coast-to-coast here Ron yeah
what what they did Arizona getting him
from the Tigers he is he has lit up this
lineup what do you think about this
offense around him tonight in this
ballgame you know think about a risk
he's only been with the team two months
and he's going to be in the top five MVP
votes for the National League I think
and you know what he's done not only to
protect Paul bullsh-- mitt he's also you
know he's the kind of guy that has power
coast-to-coast he can go to right center
or left center ah off you
he is just you know one of the greatest
pickups you've ever seen I I think he's
the best pickup late by a team since
Manny Ramirez joined the Dodgers and
then Oh a year Oh 809 or whatever and
what he's done as far as his production
and changing the team and you know he
was always hidden behind McGee Cabrera
with Detroit Tigers and others you know
Upton or whatever and here he's uh
become the star I think that most people
watch the game every day knew he would
and my apologies to Brian Anderson
you're calling the game with him tonight
not Ernie Johnson and then my kudos to
you Ron for not correcting me well I
think you were right the first time I'm
calling with Ernie Johnson or yes I am
right the first time so the whoever was
in your ear way to call him out Ron okay
okay very good so you are calling it
with Ernie Johnson this evening yeah as
well as the Cubs Nats on Friday correct
yeah pound the table for the Cubs here
Ron nobody's given them any chance I
don't think to to repeat based on what
we saw for the Dodgers this regular
season and obviously the Nats and then
with their bullpen that they fortified
at the trade deadline how on the table
for the Cubs here
Rob's where the Cubs were the best team
down the stretch that I saw I I did
their games you know maybe eight or nine
of their games down the stretch
um they were the best team that I saw
the addition of Quintana who I watched
throw a shutout on a big game in
Milwaukee a shutout is the nine innings
of not giving up a run because people
don't see that very often anymore yes
and he was he was such a great addition
to this ballclub they're starting
pitching got in line and second half
Hendricks is back better than ever
I'd be really afraid of the Cubs the
Cubs have a real chance to go all the
way through because how they played in
the second half and then I gotta ask you
one of the topics of discussion based on
last night's wild-card game was the
celebration that the Yankees had in the
clubhouse with champagne all over the
place and goggles and and and putting up
the plastic on the on the clubhouse
walls to keep everything dry a lot of
folks were like why are the Yankees
celebrating a wild-card win like it was
the World Series certainly when they got
27 in the case on that run you know I
think this is a we're old guys and this
is Millennial age and everybody gets a
trophy and everybody wants to celebrate
whatever I I'm not against it
I would think though that for most ball
clubs I think it's really fun to put the
goggles on and the champagne and all
that stuff but really the prize is
that's at some point you've got to win
you know 11 games and III think if I
were on a team I would like it to be
celebrated less but I played on a team
the 86 mat-su probably would've
celebrated more than any ones like Ron
who to let that celebration the
celebration I think would have been led
by Hernandez and Dykstra and though
those guys I think they would have been
he front and center
Heath would have been front and center
with the with the champagne huh I mean
what Davey Johnson have said David
Johnson would have been in the
background Gary Carter would have been
out in front there are the late great
see it's interesting man it's
interesting you brought up the trophy
culture because I said that too in the
first hour I'm going back and forth that
these are kids in the Yankees clubhouse
that not many people gave a shot to
actually can go a less like they did
yeah and you want to act like you've
been there before they haven't been
there before most of them in that
Clubhouse have not been there before but
then there is the trophy culture where
everybody gets an orange wedge these
days and youth sports Ron and they're
well you have to remember also last year
at this time we probably had some
discussions that the Yankees were two or
three years away from
being a contending ballclub and what
they have done there in such a quick
time now listen no one knew that Aaron
judge was going to turn into Babe Ruth
for the summer but I mean what they've
done in a year's time when most people
thought after trading Miller and Chapman
to get some help in the minor leagues
that they were going to turn to the team
they have and they're really scary and
I'm sure the Indians know that before I
let you go run back closer to home with
the Mets are they going to turn to one
of your old teammates to be the new
manager I don't know if they're going to
turn to one of the old teammates I think
in my opinion they're gonna pick someone
who has the ability to not only manage
on the field but also the deal with the
analytics that's Mets and most ball
clubs use right now so I think it'll be
a more of a new wave kind of guy really
yeah what do you think the direction of
the team is right now the collimator
mess right now
well I think we're talking about the
Yankees and how quick of a rebound they
had if the Mets get the kind of pitching
that everyone thinks they're supposed to
get from from the guys that have talent
that they have I think they could have a
quick fix to so hopefully that'll happen
because they're too talented with their
pitching for it not to work at some
point if I give you a choice choose one
of the two to finish the sentence okay
Matt Harvey is ready to rebound be toast
in New York not the toast of New York
toast in New York I am always the
eternal optimist especially when it
comes to young pitching because I had my
own pratfalls in the beginning of my
career ready to rebound and I think he's
gonna be for the second time to come
back Player of the Year okay Ron I'm
looking forward to your call with Ernie
Johnson tonight all right thank on TBS
am i right down the line you got it Ron
darling the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint